the doom reboot will have the usual
multiplayer modes like deathmatch and
domination and freeze tag but that's
probably not your main concern I bet you
just want to know when that multiplayer
beta is starting well Bethesda released
a new multiplayer trailer that finally
has the answer the closed beta will run
from March 31st through april third the
beta will be available on ps4 Xbox one
and PC anybody who pre-ordered woven
stein the old blood and redeemed their
code will finally be able to hop into
the multiplayer they were promised its
software teamed up with developer
certain affinity to build dooms
multiplayer certain affinity has also
worked on the Halo and Call of Duty
franchises so all you betta players
should enjoy what they have to offer
stoom releases for ps4 xbox one and pc
on May 13 its software recently ran a
poll to determine the game's reversible
cover art so you can look forward to
rocking that alternate look on launch
day until then keep it locked to
gamespot for all the doom news you need